John thank you so much for sitting here
and chatting with me about what is I
think the best movie that I've ever seen
oh my gosh Thank You Justine you're only
saying that we have been friends for a
long time lots of people don't know that
but like Justine has participated in
almost every project for awesome ever
you've built like wells around the world
did there's there's still a few that are
there due to be built in the next couple
of years it was really so cool no but
it's so crazy cause like I still see you
as a youtuber so I still I still see
myself as YouTube I know but like seeing
your Instagram start popping up at like
the mtv movie awards for you what has
this whole thing been like it's been
very weird because i still love like I
love you too bye love my YouTube friends
and Hollywood is cool but that's where
my heart is um but it was amazing I
think I'm TV movie awards i was sitting
I was sitting seven seats away from
David Hasselhoff oh my god yeah it's
about the highlight of my life I
couldn't watch what was happening on
stage because I was so busy watching
Hasselhoff watch what was happening on
stage and what was well I mean that's
kind of amazing I mean what was he
watching like what was his reaction he
was a very um I don't I got the feeling
that maybe it wasn't them the most
excited day of his life yeah what he's
had a really exciting life he hands you
know so like for me I was like this is
as good as it gets and for the Hoff I
think it was just another award show for
like the youtubers at home like watching
I mean if they've been here throughout
this whole process I mean how do you
think the nerdfighters are gonna kind of
take to the movie they're great i mean
the good thing about the movie is that
they really worried about nerdfighteria
like they were really scared about the
fans of the book which is good because i
think that's part of why the movies so
good i think that they won't had a
healthy fear of displeasing people who
love the book and i was on set almost
the entire time and I care about the
book a lot obviously and I just thought
they did a great job they really did cuz
I you've seen it I did I saw it and I
had no idea I showed up the screening
thinking it was one of those screenings
where they shove you in a room you're
alone so I rolled out of bed go to the
screening I was like oh my god there's
like hundreds of people you guys the
whole cast was there I was like well all
right she will have fantastic well thank
you
but it was so cool and and shadeland did
such a great job she's an amazing
actress I couldn't believe it I've never
actually seen her play a role like that
no I mean a welder I don't think there
are a lot of roles in Hollywood like
that where you know she's wearing a
canela and her nose for almost every
frame of the movie and she's just
brilliant in it she just you know when
you're writing a book you hear the
characters voices in your head and they
have a very particular way of speaking
and I worried a lot about that on the
set I thought you know this is gonna be
weird for me I'm gonna have to shut up
and not say like no no she says it like
this mm-hmm but which with shailene and
Ansel who plays Gus like they just
sounded like hazel and Gus to me from
the very beginning he did it was so cute
and like hearing people watching the
movie anytime I'd hear their favorite
lines they would go yeah I would hear
little sobs and little gas I honestly
cried throughout the whole movie and
something you said when somebody asked
you something about the book I remember
the question was but you said you wrote
the book and then you gave it to them
like it was theirs I hope that was
awesome because each person in that
theater I feel like they were watching
the movie but for them they were feeling
something different and relating that to
something in their life that's is you
think that's like it sort of the case
yeah i think that like I think that
books and movies and YouTube YouTube
stuff too like it has to be a gift you
know it has to be something that you
make for someone and then you let you
say to them like go and take this and if
it can be useful to you great I hope it
can be I worked really hard on it i hope
that you like this i hope that you know
and that's all you can do um and it's
hard it's hard to let go because you
know obviously you like the stuff that
you made and you work really hard on it
but you have to be able to let it go but
what's cool about is you know I was
relating it to situations that I had
been and friends that I had lost and I
think it's cool to be able to see these
characters dealing with that and then
you can kind of deal at the same time I
don't know it's just yeah I mean we've
all we've all lost people who are
important to us and um it's it's not
something it you know it's funny like a
lot of times people say like oh you'll
get over it or time heals all wounds or
whatever but it's not something you want
to get over necessarily I don't want to
stop remembering my friends I don't want
to stop caring about them and I want to
live with that loss I want to be okay
with it i want i know that they would
want me to go on living but i thought
doesn't mean that you want to forget
I was it was great i'm so excited and
another thing you shot a lot of this in
pittsburgh yes I'm from Pittsburgh I
love Pittsburgh everyone that's from
Pittsburgh loves the city so what did
you think about it I was blown away by
Pittsburgh I live in Indianapolis I love
in Annapolis nothing against
Indianapolis great city Pittsburgh is
like Indianapolis plus you need apolis
plus Hills you know yeah it was actually
really hard cuz the movies set in
Indianapolis but it was filmed in
Pittsburgh so we had to find flat
streets that's kind of hard to do it is
it's hard to do like it's just such a
hilly city there's so much there's so
much photography there's amazing
restaurants in really great restaurants
shailene is a huge fan of like farm to
table food and organics and even raw
food I went to a raw-food restaurant on
like two or three occasions and that was
a different thing for me i'm used to i'm
a big fan of heat like I think it's
amazing when we invented fire I like to
celebrate that moment by eating warm
food woman she has such a strict diet so
that's awesome that she was able to find
yeah yeah there were all these great
restaurants that she was able to find
and yeah so I had wrong raw food with
shame eating couple times I have to say
that like this particular restaurant in
Pittsburgh made some good raw food like
good raw banana bread and the whole
thing was really cool but yet I love the
city I love the people in the city like
almost everybody who worked on the movie
this is really moving to me um yeah it's
like 150 people who work on a movie is
the people who you know drive the stars
to and from their apartments and the
people who scout locations and the
people who like build sets and
everything almost everyone read the book
that's cool um and almost everybody with
I mean I think everybody was there
because they cared about the story and
it's just so magical it was the opposite
of like what an author expects a
Hollywood experience to be like
everybody was so cool and I think was
because it was in Pittsburgh yeah you
know just like a zit person from Indiana
I felt very at home there it is it's a
very homey city and I mean I have so
many friends there and everyone has been
so awesome I know there's a lot of
movies and stuff that have been coming
through there yeah that's good because
they've prepped for that so ya ready
they have a great like they have great
crew um a lot of those people
made some of my favorite movies like
they made wonder boys they made jack
reacher which I thought was like Tom
Cruise's best movie of the last five
years I do too I'm not apologizing yeah
exactly it's not just cuz I'm a
Pittsburgh fanboy I also would gitam
movie but that was so scary seeing those
scenes and like places that I walked and
I grew up yeah hey there's a sniper I'm
like oh my god anytime I even drive
through the bridge of like okay you're
going nerve you're fine did you have
that experience I don't know which way
you're coming from but when you first
drive through the 20 come out of the
tunnel then you see the city it's
amazing like you can't even explain that
if anyone has ever seen that like it's
just the coolest thing ever I mean one
of the reasons it is worth going to
pittsburgh is for that experience i also
went up this the duquesne incline
incline yeah which I have a terrible
fear of heights and my son was three at
the time and we were going up to
duquesne incline with my son and my wife
who was pregnant and nope just kidding
we had a second baby okay said she was
outside of the body yeah real i
remembered that now yep superfresh could
have been inside could've been had that
young so anyway we're going up to
duquesne incline and henry was like this
is so fun and i was having an actual
panic attack and he was like daddy look
out the window it has like he's like
daddy what's wrong with you and I was
like nothing nothing nothing's wrong
with me man nothing he was like he was
like daddy's scared to look out the
window mommy and is like I'm not scared
he was like who got the window and as I
gonna want to look out the window he
made me three again I mean and that
things like a vintage cart oh no I was
convinced that I was in the last five
minutes of my life the scariest thing
ever yeah totally I'm so another
question I wanted to ask you at the
screening but I was too busy crying my
eyes out and I couldn't talk what was
the casting process like because
obviously you have these characters in
your mind so did you sit in on the
casting and like I didn't sitting like I
didn't go to the auditions but they sent
me the audition tapes so um I saw more
than 100 tapes for hazel but then
shailene auditioned blade in the process
and they sent me she leans tape and I
think everybody agreed that it had to be
her I mean it whoever to the casting you
guys did a great job yeah Raonic rest
she did an amazing job the whole I mean
I thought Willem Dafoe was amazing and
spin out and laura dern as Hazel's mom I
am clear I found out that he was gonna
be
that movie I mean Oh boondock saints ya
know ya willin to flow has been in so
many good movies also his parents grew
up ten houses away from me on Orlando
Florida yeah so I like when I was
walking my dog when I was a little kid
when I was like eight years old I would
see willem dafoe like at his parents
house for Thanksgiving oh my gosh and so
forth at him to be in my movie he did
such a good job everybody did such a
great job I know the performances are
amazing I'm so proud of everybody who
worked so hard on that movie I'm so
happy for you like honestly like it it's
I think this is just it's just I'm
speechless honestly Thank You Justine
your toilet died I'm so glad you because
we've been you know like we've been
doing this thing together for so long um
then it's been so wonderful to watch
your life take all of its turns and your
career go so wonderfully and um yeah I
just feel really grateful that I have
all of these amazing people in my life
who are my friends who all are also like
supportive of my work it means a lot to
me I think that's what kind of goes back
to the original YouTube community yeah i
mean it is and it's still there like
it's there you know we are still a
community there's a lot of other stuff
happening on youtube and that's fine
yeah but we are still a community and
that's so important to me yes we love
you guys we do genuinely um what's the I
don't know how much time I could like
sit here for three hours so I don't know
we can do that okay we could just do a
sit you're smiling I was giving my
serious you're being super cute you
don't even have a serious face I do when
I'm when I have no emotion i'm just
sitting like you show me your show me
your show me your emotional space you do
a kind of a mean emotional speculate are
you mad and like no I'm on we there's a
woman who works in my office um who has
a very mad normal face yeah it's awful
because people always think I'm upset or
angry I'm like nope I'm I'm perfectly
fine this is just my face it's just my
face I can't help it yeah I did have one
other question um what would be a
question that no one asked you while on
tour that you were like I can't believe
nobody asked me this no one ever asked
me about Willem Dafoe and its really I
never talked about him and I was I felt
bad because I was like I'm sure will and
Defoe doesn't watch like Access
Hollywood or whatever but like I was
like feeling
be talking about Willem Dafoe um what's
another question that no one asked me
what I will talk about him all day long
because so cool one of my favorite
people and I like he's also I mean he
cut like so often he plays like these
terrible terrible people including and
fault in our stars but he's really good
at it yeah but he's all he's a lovely
man and extremely professional and
focused like he came to Pittsburgh
prepared again so ready and that was
very impressive to me because he's
obviously a very famous well-established
actor but he was good like he is good at
his job it's always amazing to see
people who are really competent mmm cuz
I'm not you know like i'm kind of an
incompetent person generally so i'm
always just like astonished by people's
confidence yeah you're like high five
for you buddy anybody who can like like
change a doorknob or change the oil in
their car I can't do that either like we
can make youtube videos we've got that
we're pretty good at editing yeah
Justine's better at editing that I am I
mean well I don't know about that no
it's true it's true I can only do one
kind of edit it's called a jump cut
that's all you need to know it's good to
start that's where you start and then we
just make some transition nope after
eight years still just the jump cut I
mean if you did you ever think that when
you first started making YouTube videos
that any of this would have ever
happened no I mean I'm sure that you're
in the same boat when when we started
making YouTube videos it never occurred
to us that this could be a job it's just
the thing that I liked doing it's a
chance to talk to my brother and other
people I liked yeah and here you are a
crazy movie oh my gosh here we are in
your real living room yeah you're
beautiful real life living room they
asked me to like what's set what you
guys like to be sitting at I was like I
don't know a wall I don't care we got a
really nice wall we had the option of a
bar i was like maybe that's a little
weird yeah we're just gonna living out i
wish that our um i wish that the wall in
my actual house looked like that i don't
have a single piece of art in my house
you don't owe my wife is an art curator
she will help you she will give you
great art very cheap great the only
thing that I have and it's still not
even framed is the original mac logo
it's Susan kare designed and she has
Prince of its that's the only thing I
have that is a cool piece of art
original you gotta frame it I know
rolled up Frank do something a bit oh my
god Justine this is not acceptable I
know well thank you so much for chatting
with me is there anything else you want
to tell them about the movie that that
you haven't told anybody oh it comes out
on june sixth so let's go see it or not
it's up to you but um i just want to say
thank you it's so nice to see you I'm
such a big fan of yours so it's fun to
hang out I'm your biggest fan oh my gosh
oh and the soundtrack is really good too
yeah the soundtrack isn't bad yeah
really good I also pre-ordered it oh
well good good son okay well that's it I
love you guys we love you go see the
movie and let us know what you think of
it dftba